hi Liz oh hi I couldn't be more proud of
you it's quite amazing what you've been
through the last few months huh oh and
yes and shower you run the jewels pin
damn right
[ __ ] yes right right it you know what
you know turn lettuce between are we
going to guess that is LP okay I just
like killer Maya because we like Bernie
so the last few months this is
surprising to you um well no it's just
um exciting and I think that my whole
life you know I've been creating music
and I've been performing shows so I've
always felt really successful I think
that's my definition of success but as
my music started to help people yeah and
help you know change how people felt and
made it more positive one of my goals
was for my music to finally reach as
many people as possible so that's what
I'm feeling more I'm overwhelmed with
pride and I'm just so proud of the fact
that people are they want to be happier
they want to love themselves that's the
only reason why my music is catching one
that's the only reason why I truth hurts
is on the charts right now cuz everyone
wants to be a hundred percent that [ __ ]
you know what I mean when I 100 percent
that [ __ ] could I be that of course so
I I find this to be so inspiring because
I don't and I said this earlier it's
part beyonce part Oprah I mean you're
testifying on stage and your your
teaching life lessons that's got to come
from an enormous place of strength and
security from you I wonder if you ever
get insecure if you ever get worried if
you ever get fearful well I mean I'm
actually learning on site so yes thank
you
believe it or not what I'm saying on
stage isn't to people but it's with
people it's conversational I'm learning
new things every night on stage about
myself and about how to manage my life
better like on this tour I actually had
a really rough start um coming straight
from Coachella
and I had been beating myself up because
of Coachella and technical difficulties
and and then I was sick immediately and
I was just like oh my god this sucks
like I'm not I'm not gonna be good
enough I'm not gonna sing good enough I
feel bad I wish I could be a hundred so
um I actually was at a pretty low point
and I would have conversations with the
crowds in the first few shows and just
trying to figure out what the [ __ ] was
going on and like how can I build myself
back up from this low point that I was
at and when I as I was talking to them I
realized that that is a part of it
that's a part of self-love that's a part
of self-care it's why we do so much
self-care because when we're beating
ourselves up and when it's actually not
all sunshine and roses we have this
foundation that we've laid down to help
pick us back up a little easier so I
found myself able to bounce back from my
low point on this tour way quicker um so
yeah so other than other than doing
therapy on stage with an audience where
do you where do you go for for
inspiration where do you go in the low
moments where who do you turn to because
I mean I I just watched 300 people turn
to you and that's the last side of
Nashville I saw you know a thousand
people turn to you who do you turn to
real therapy that will my therapist I'm
just gonna shout to Gail I'm like my
girl Gail well you know I have a really
amazing group of people around me that
my best friends also tour with me and
they were my best friends before we
toured and then a lot of the people who
tour with me have become my best friends
from the dancers to my glam team so
we're all on the same path we all want
to be more positive minded self loving
happier people so when you have a group
of people like that around you there's
no way any of that can darkness can
exist they're gonna get rid of that [ __ ]
so quick and sometimes you know I think
it's just communicating learning how to
open up your mouth and just say how you
feel which has been really hard for me
my whole life and I don't know I think
it's because of us and I said this last
night like you know I was taught to like
be very strong and hold back my emotions
to make sure everyone else was
comfortable when I was little and it's a
part of being a black woman - like we're
so strong we take so much on and it's
it's this inherent thing it's this very
innate thing but then it's also this
socially taught thing from from young
age so um I was the baby in the family
but I was always the rock and I would
hold things down and but the older I get
the more I realize I was repressed and I
didn't get to express myself I didn't
get to cry I didn't but if I didn't get
to cry that means I didn't get to really
fully love and I didn't get to really
fully laugh and really fully be angry I
didn't allow myself you know a spectrum
of emotions yeah you can't be just safe
all the time
and I think that um my friends around me
allow me to go to those extremes without
turning their backs on me and they're
and they embrace that because they know
that I'm late for the party I'm late to
the emotions but but you're there anyway
that's all it matters you're at the
party it's all it matters and and that
goes into every song that you write
there is a distinct message every time
that you you seem to not just speak but
sing there's there's a common thread
through it all well thank you and it's
my voice that's what it is and I and I'm
on this journey to find my voice and I'm
on this journey to love myself and so I
think that that's just if you don't love
yourself well gonna love you can I get
an amen
what does RuPaul say you're asking me
okay wait if you can't love yourself how
the hell you gonna love somebody else
can I get an amen that's right um don't
put that part in there I butchered
RuPaul I'm trying to get back on the
show but exactly um and and that's that
that was the first half of my messaging
on the coconut oil tours I would always
be like you need to love yourself and
fill yourself up with yourself so that
you can be better to the people around
you and that's what I was trying to
learn but we're taking it a step further
now where it's like you need to be
complete with yourself and be your own
soul mate and stop searching for
something outside of yourself and stand
still in yourself so that you can
attract all of that love that is
purposed for you everything that you
deserve all that good [ __ ] that's
floating around
waiting for you is attracted to you once
you're just in love with you so you
might have you might have just now come
to the party but you're billowing
through the party I mean you're you're
running through it with like a chair
almost and swinging it because I mean I
don't know when you got there but boy
you're there and and it's it's exude
exudes from you and I think that's
that's the I think that's the magnetic
part of you yeah and that's the reason
why we love you so much
well I mean it took my whole life to get
to the Met Gala but I went and I [ __ ]
shut that [ __ ] down so the funniest
video I've ever seen is walking through
the airport with that jacket
what was the rental cost of that extra
day yeah they can make thing hey no
that's my coat my name they gave it to
you it's yours it's official Izzo Met
Gala 2019 you carry it with you
everywhere you go now it's literally
inside my [ __ ] I was gonna ask to wear
it but you know you was playing the song
first appreciate you I appreciate so
much I love you so much and I I said
this on stage you're the best part of
the industry you're the best player you
represent everything that's great with
humanity we need so many more of you so
I love you to death that's the goal the
goal is to just represent me and so that
other people can believe in the me in
themselves so that they can do this to
go do it I love you Jada great thank you
so much thank you
you